hello my name is Thomas Lee zurai and
I'd like to present our work efficiently
testable circuits this work has been
done together with nirsahar Bai shuvra
de factraborty Stefan jamboski malgozata
gowanska and Christopher
we consider the problem of tempering the
circles
a device implementing the functionality
f is given
and then it's handed to some adversary
and this adversary May tamper with the
device
finally the device is given to the end
user and may be installed in his device
and the question is whether this device
still implements the functionality of
what is the tampering model that we
assume the temperate butter was actually
introduced by isai atalia in their work
private circuits too in the model A
Boolean circuit is given and described
with a duck and then the adversary is
able to tamper with the wires of the
circle by setting each wire to a
constant zero setting it to a constant
one toggling it or doing nothing with
the wire we also assume conductivity
assumption introduced by isai atalia in
our work
in the conductivity assumption we are
given wires which I which are copied to
end distinct locations
and the adversary is able to apply only
one tampering to all sub parts of such
wires
whenever the wires are copied to at most
and locations in the whole circuit we
say that the circuit is n conductive
of course the trivia solution to
protects protect against errors
which come up in circuit stampered in
such a way is to do Brute Force testing
by Brute Force testing I mean that one
could check
how that circuit behaves given all the
possible inputs to the circuit
but we assume that these circuits may
have large input size even more than 100
input wires
there are two major lines of work which
are related to our work
the first one is the already Dimension
private circuits too
they were they encode each wire into two
wires to either 0 1 or 1 0 and then the
secrets share each original input wire
finally whenever some error occurs
this error will be cascaded through a
Cascade of gadgets into the output which
means that whenever an error occurs
the output of the circuit will be zero
zeroed out
then setting is secure against any
number of set to zero tamperings
or less than T arbitrary tamperings
where T is the size of Dimension
secretion
the second flight of line of work that
is related to ours is on heuristic
testing
this works stem from Hardware testing
community and they are focused on
testing against benign
non-adversarial errors which are created
during the record that production phase
of a device
some heuristics are given in a
well-established literature for example
this book cited on this slide
and they give presumably High rate of
success
given some distribution or on of errors
but it's never 100 percent and never
assuming adversarial errors
I will work we propose a compiler for
circuits and a testing procedure we
assume adversarial
arrows and we assume that adversary May
introduce any number of these errors in
into the circuit and then the compiler
compiles a circuit into a one which is
only constant times larger than the
original
and of course we proposed an efficient
testing procedure for the compiled
surface
in our approach we give a compiler that
compiles any circuit C with s input bits
and T output bits into a pair c h t hat
such that this secret is a new circle
with additional s trim and t-prem
input and output bits and T hat is the
testing set which is a subset of all
possible inputs
to the new compiled circuit
and then this new circuit must be
functionally equivalent to C which means
given any input to the original circuit
the compiled circuit will output on the
first T output beats something equal to
the output of the original circuit what
is more this pair C hat T hat must be
testable which means for any tampering
Tau applied to wires of the circuit
Whenever there is some inconsistency on
the outputs of the compiled circuit
then the inconsistency can be also
detected by going through the inputs of
the testing set
this property implicitly gives us
efficient testing procedure
in the following slides we will present
the construction of the compiler based
on some very simple example
the example will be given for a function
X1 and X2 or X3 and X4 and it will be
described with with such simple building
settlement
before we present the actual
construction of our compiler we will
present the idea of covering sets
the covering set D is a set set such
that every wire of the circuit is
evaluated to both 0 and 1 given some
inputs from T in our example
the covering set would be simply all
zeros input and all one's input
but in general this covering set might
not exist or even be hard to find for
some complex sentence
but whenever we have some C for which
the covering set is hard to find or even
impossible to find then we can
pre-process it into a pair C Prime T
Prime
the C Prime would be will be a new
circuit functionally equivalent to C and
C Prime will have covering set T Prime
and how do I achieve this we achieve
this by modifying evaluation of output
wires of some gates by adding sore gates
to their input wires and disk or Gates
will be connected directly to some new
input bits which we call control bits
so let's say we have an and gate
its inputs are already covered which
means that they are evaluated to both 0
and 1 given some inputs but maybe they
never get
evaluated to one
at the same time which means we never
get one at the output of the gate
now whether we add a new circuit
connected to some control wire
then this sword gate may make the right
inputs wire evaluate to one
and then at some point the output of the
and gate can also get evaluated to 1. in
general we will need only three control
bits to pre-process the whole circuit
now we will present some trivial
solution to our problem
we are a gamer master I could see with
the covering set team and what we do we
output all intermediary values in the
circuit directly to the output of the
circuit
and because we have the covering set T
what we can do we can do input output
testing on all elements from discovering
set t
now whenever we have some topologically
first
tampering in the circuit
and we know that this wire will be
evaluated to both 0 and 1 given some
inputs from the covering set t
then there must occur an error during
the evaluation
and because this wire is conductivically
attached to the output of the circuit
this error will be also detected
directly on the output of this circuit
this construction remains too conductive
whenever the input circuit was one
conducted
the drawback of this construction
however is that it outputs too many
output repeats to the construction
normally we assume that the circuit has
around 100
input and output bits and it can have
around 1 million Gates inside
this means that we would need to add
around Millions output wires to the
Circuit which is an unrealistic
assumption
if the following slides I will present
how to decrease the number of the output
pins in such Construction
slide presents a partial solution to the
problem with the decreased output size
of the compiled circuit
so we are again given a circuit C with a
covering set T and what we do is we
connect all the intermediary values in
the circuit to change of and and or
Gates
let's assume at this point that these
chains themselves are not standard
of course the input wires to the
exchange can be tempered but the
intermediary values in the chains and
their output pins cannot be tempered
we again do input output testing on the
modified circuit
on all elements from the covering set t
and though the solution will again
detect topologically first tampering
that will produce
some error
and because this error is evaluated to
both and and or chain then for example
if this when we know that all the wires
of the circuit should be evaluated to
zero and an error occurs that evaluates
some wire to one then this wire will
connect to the or chain and because we
know that the output of the or chain
should be zero and we have the error the
error will switch the output
of the art chain
this construction remains three
conductive given a circuit that was one
conductive at the very beginning because
each wire is connected to two gates one
gate from end chain and the other gate
from the r chain
in the following slides I will say how
to get rid of this assumption that this
end and all chains cannot be tampered to
make sure that the construction is
secure
before we proceed I will introduce the
multi-order gadget
actually it's a chain of or Gates
connected to a single control bit at the
very beginning
and given c equal to zero they the
gadget still computes the r of the
inputs of the gadget
but if any of the input values is
numbered to one at some point and we
know that all of them should be zero
then the multi or
will not switch when we switch the
control bit but naturally when all of
the input bits should be zero switching
the C should also switch the output of
the gadget
analogically we can Define the multi-end
gadget
now I will present the first four
solution to our problem
so the previous Construction
we will replace the chains of and and or
Gates
by the multi-end
multi-org gadgets simply by adding a
control bit
and
given some input from the testing set
that evaluates maybe all the wires of
the circuit to zeros
we know that whenever some tampering
occurs in the circuit and this
topologically first dampering me for
example set this wire to one
we will see that the one of the chains
like the multi or Gadget will not switch
its output given switching control bit
actually
we can
do such evaluation in the testing phase
by simply adjusting the testing the the
covering set
by adding all evaluations of the control
wire
to the testing inputs
analogically we we can describe our
functionality in terms of the m and
multi-end Gadget
the drawback of the construction however
is its large depth
produced by the long
multi-end multi-aut chains
and how do we decrease the depth of our
construction we apply some recursive
strategy with L layers where NL is a
small integer value
the example will give will be given for
two layers
and how do we construct another layer of
our construction when we have two layers
we will divide the long chains
into shorter parts
subparts of square root of n length so
we will have square root of n such sub
parts
and we will connect these sub parts to
the chains of end
and or in the next layer
now when we switch the seabeat in the
first layer we know that appropriate
chain for example all chain should
switch accordingly
and then
to again detect whether the outputs
switch properly in the second player we
apply the new control bit the the text
the text a similar property in this
layer
we can realize this testing process by
simply adding all evaluations of both
control Beats
to their original inputs of the testing
set
the depth of the circuit Rises at most L
times
nth root of M
with L players of the construction
what about the parameters of a
construction
assuming a circuit with input size s
output size T number of gates n and
circuit depth d
after pre-processing we will add only
three new input bits and the size of the
circuit will rise only at most three
times
the Circuit of the the circuit depth
will rise on the logarithmically
now when we will finally compile our
circuit with L layers we will again add
all new input bits
two to DL output bits
but the size of the circuit will arise
only linearly
and the second depth will rise only L
times and through root of 3M
this test size will remain small because
of the small L parameter and it will be
4 times 2 to the L
we strongly encourage you to continue to
study of the tampering models
the first thing that one could try to do
is to remove the Assumption of
conductivity
we have already solved this problem in
some other work since we put it as our
priority after finishing this work we
will try to publish the results soon the
second problem is the problem of gates
tampering in the problem of gate
tampering one could assume that the
adversary could switch current gates
with some other Gates but the topology
of the circuit would still remain the
same
the third problem is the is the idea to
allow modifications of the topology of
the circle for example by adding new
gates to the Circuit or removing some of
them from the circuit
thank you for your attention